the One Piece manga just introduced
something to the story that I would not
have expected even in my wildest dreams
Bonnie and Luffy have just discovered an
actual lightsaber inside vegapung's
laboratory in other words there's now an
actual possibility that we will see a
lightsaber wielding Zorro in the story
of One Piece it might also be even more
foreshadowing that Luffy and his crew
will go to space at some point in the
story based on all the moon and Rocket
related technology that we've already
seen in one piece and on top of that
bunny has turned Luffy into a 70 year
old man something that ichiroda had
drawn before in an SBS not the
successful pirate king version though
that looks a lot like Garb but Luffy if
he doesn't achieve his dream Kuma might
be the second known character now next
to King who is part of the lunarian race
and while Zorro is mistrusting vegapunk
number two vegapunk number one is in
direct contract with the revolutionaries
talking about his death meanwhile aokiji
is confirmed as an official member of
Blackbeard's crew for the very first
time I'm looting whole cake Island while
law and his men put up a way better
fight against each than any of us could
have ever imagined does law have a real
chance to win this after all what is
vegapung's true goal here is Luffy's new
form foreshadowing for a dark future and
most importantly will we see a triple
wielding Darth Zorro as an official part
of the story Well turns out we might
already know the answers to all of these
the current eckhit island arc is the
first part of One Piece final Saga and
just as Oda promised it has been setting
new standards for the story already
currently there are two ongoing plot
lines running in parallel the straw hats
Adventure inside the headquarters of the
genius scientist vegapunk and the epic
Clash between Blackbeard and law teach
has ambushed Luffy's brother in arms to
get his hands on kaido's poniglyph after
his defeat we've actually kind of found
out that Blackbeard didn't have any of
the road Pony glyphs necessary to find
the final Island Loft tale quite yet but
instead that just waited patiently and
equipped his crew with the most powerful
devil fruits in order to Simply take
that information from someone else they
could just do the dirty work for him as
a result a lot is at stake in this fight
aokiji and Van auger have gotten their
hands on big mom's Road poniglyph as
well as pudding so teach already has one
stone that law hasn't plus someone who
can actually decipher its meaning should
La lose Blackbeard will not only have
the legendary opioid me in his grasp but
also get the two Road poniglyphs law has
from zou and from wano which would then
have him draw even with Luffy plus he
has three hostages law putting in Kobe
to draw Luffy once he gets his hands on
the fourth one and I'll get to that
fight in just a second meanwhile it
seems like the strides have had a much
better draw with their rival at Egghead
Islands they most likely aren't only
about to get a whole lot of sacred
information about devil fruits and the
history of the world from vegapunk but
quite possibly also receive some
decisive power upgrades on top after all
the island and its Tech technology are
500 years ahead of the rest of the world
which Oda has shown Us in the form of
countless Advanced Technologies
including a freaking lightsaber a weapon
that clearly is inspired by Star Wars
and we all know just how deadly and
Powerful a weapon like this is in that
universe so the big question is is this
simply a funny little Easter egg that
Oda has thrown into the story or does
this futuristic weapon serve a much more
important role for the plot here I mean
after all we have a powerful
swordsmaster who wants to be able to cut
through anything or could this serve an
even bigger purpose well let's look at
the evidence the lightsaber by itself
already begs to be used in my opinion
just looking at it as it is and seeing
Luffy's reaction to it it definitely
wouldn't be the first futuristic weapon
related to vegapunk in the straw hat
crew either after all as you can see in
these panels we have Frankie's cyborg
Powers nami's climate act and sanji's
genetic modifications
ever turn Zoro into to the one piece
version of a Jedi or a Sith though but
we don't really have to wonder because
he has already done that twice this is
the official artwork that Oda did in
1999 for the release of the phantom
menace movie with Zorro as Anakin
Skywalker and then in 2015 for the
release of the force awakens he drew all
of the straw hats as Star Wars figures
as well again Zorro as a Jedi slash Sif
and of course we have all the other
space related technology in one piece
we've seen a ton of Rocket shaped
objects in the lab there are ships
capable of space travel like nl's Ark
Maxime and of course we already know
from annel's cover story that there used
to be a whole civilization on one of the
one piece moons with advanced technology
and of course there are space pirates
now does all of this prove that Zorro
will start yielding a lightsaber for the
rest of the series oh yeah it could I
mean each of the order has been a big
sci-fi and Star Wars fan and taken a lot
of inspiration from it for his own story
if you'd like to see a bit more proof
when you look at the reflection of this
TV in oda's office you can see that he
has a life-size model of R2D2 parked
under a shelf he also has this life-size
Terminator by the way in case you were
curious where the inspiration for
Frankie came from now of course it's
very possible that the lightsaber could
just end up being a small token of
appreciation for the Star Wars story or
simply a gadget that Zorro or some other
character also uses in the story at some
point but it could also mean much much
more than this as you know Oda usually
doesn't just draw attention to something
for no good reason and the connection to
Zorro is quite obvious too lightsaber or
laser sword and the crew swordsman Oda
clearly thought along the same lines as
well drawing Zorro as a force wielder
more than just once and as far back as
1999 so I do think it's kind of obvious
that he'd at least like to draw
something like this in the story it just
might have been the upgrade that Zorro
has been waiting for looking for a
unique weapon that truly can cut any
anything and would allow for completely
new techniques and powers from here on
out and while I do find it very unlikely
that he will trade in all of his
traditional blades for lightsabers as
awesome as that would be he might simply
wield this one as a special fourth
weapon from now on or he could simply
keep it safe until he needs it for
example in case that the straw hats ever
went to space because as you've seen
there are a lot of things hinting at
just that there's actually quite a lot
of evidence out there that love tail
itself may be located on the moon but
that's a whole different video let me
know if you'd like to see that but to
stick with the evidence so far we do
know that there are space pirates in one
piece similar to what we have in Star
Wars there's an ancient and lost city
slash Temple of an advanced civilization
on the moon again similar to Star Wars
and all of its ancient history and lore
and even if this one is stretching it a
little bit I know but if you wanted to
you could make the case that haki and
the force are not all too different
either I mean just like the force you
can use hockey to control living things
and increase your fighting ability while
its strength is completely dependent on
the user's strength of Will and training
I mean really is as Obi-Wan a character
as it gets when he teaches Luffy hockey
you could say so should the story
actually one day take us to space which
would be pretty cool a lightsaber or
three would really be the only
appropriate weapon for Zoro then at that
point and now we know that this
technology actually exists which I think
is a win no matter what the truth is in
the end vegapunk is really adding
endless new possibilities to the story
and hopefully the crew will leave with a
bunch of power upgrades no matter what
but really what is it that vegapunk is
up to here the manga just told us a
little bit more about that as well we do
know by now that Dr vegapunk is not just
one person but an entity consisting of
one original body and six clones and
while we really don't quite know yet how
exactly this all works each of these six
versions of vegapunk can think and act
independently with their own name
personality and agenda if you want a
detailed breakdown of each of these six
Inspirations and possible research goals
well I made a whole video about that
that you can check out later but for
this let's look at the three Mega punks
that we've met so far Vega Punk number
one Shaka based on a famous Zulu King
Vega Punk number two Lilith based on
Adam's first wife who was banished from
Paradise and then turned into the first
Arc demon and vegapunk number five Atlas
who is based on the Titan who was then
sentenced to carrying the heavens on his
shoulders Shaka seems to have a lot of
authority as he's able to command Lilith
to bring the remaining straw hats to him
he also is in contact to Dragon finally
confirming the connection between
vegapunk and the revolutionaries that
we've all been speculating about Lilith
on the other hand seems to be quite
aggressive and battle hungry she wanted
to get rid of the straw hats the moment
that she saw it and Zorro has decided to
stay and protect the Sunny with Brooke
because he doesn't fully trust Lilith
and Atlas seems to have a quite simple
and actually kind personality so far
which does seem to clash a little bit
with her trait of violence and we
haven't seen any of the remaining three
Vega punks nor the original body so far
now obviously we're still very early in
this Arc we don't really know yet how
the entire Vega Punk with seven bodies
things really works and what
relationship each of them has to each
other but based on the evidence that
we've gotten so far I really like the
idea that since each vegapunk can make
their own decisions with their own
personality each of them could have
different agendas as well Shaka for
instance could be the Vega Punk that has
been feeding information and Technology
to the revolutionaries and helping them
with Kuma meanwhile a character like
Lilith could be loyal to the world
government well maybe again another one
might become friends with pirates like
Luffy so the answer to whose side Vega
Punk is on here could simply be in
everybody's and nobody's in a way and I
personally find that a very intriguing
premise for this entire Arc because that
could mean that we could have factions
of vegapunk's identity fighting with
each other and amongst each other kind
of a little bit like the Pixar movie
Inside Out where vegapunk has
personified different parts of himself I
like this idea a lot because we still
don't really have a clear objective or
villain for this archaea the strides
have no gold right now no one to meet up
with no one to defeat yet just
sightseeing basically so having vegapunk
be the villain and an ally in this Arc
would be pretty cool especially with zp
zero in the mix on top of that we have
to reveal that Kuma is not only Bonnie's
father and a former revolutionary but
also from a special race which given his
dark skin most likely means that Kuma is
a lunarian just like King this would of
course explain quite a lot for example
why vegapunk wanted to experiment on him
like he did with King who as we know
escaped and why the Posse fista have now
evolved into the seraphim that have
really strong lunarian properties at the
same time Luffy has now been turned into
this 17 year old version of himself that
has drawn before as the bad timeline
quote unquote in this reality Luffy
never fulfills his dream to become
pirate king and ends up bitter and
hopeless now does this mean that Luffy's
future right now means that he will not
reach his dream what I really like about
this is that Bonnie could turn Luffy old
once again a second time and this time
he's actually the successful version
that looks like Garb symbolizing that
Luffy's now on the right path again I
mean who knows maybe he's on the wrong
path right now because of Luffy's
biggest rival Blackbeard threatening to
catch up to him and taking one of his
biggest allies hostage and really the
fighting sequence between law and teach
so far is really something else I mean
we all kind of knew that law was strong
but he really is holding his ground here
much better than I anticipated I gotta
be honest he clearly has learned a lot
from his fight with kaido and big mom I
mean law uses his awakened abilities
quite comfortably here managing to land
some serious hits on Blackbeard who
counters with both of his devil food
abilities and really I'm especially
surprised to see that last crew is
holding themselves against Blackbeard's
crew I did not see that coming
especially because last crew was not
involved at all in the raid on
onigashima really turns out they can
actually fight good for them now I will
stick to my opinion that lob despite how
strong he has gotten and how good it's
to see him stand his grounds has no real
chance of winning this simply because it
would make no sense story wise however
seeing how he's fighting right now I do
believe that he might be able to get
away instead of being captured one way
or another I do think that Blackbeard
will get his hands on lost to poneglyphs
in the end here really raising the
stakes between him and Luffy to as high
as possible because if not now then when
will teach get those two stones I mean
he has planned all of this so carefully
for many many years that he really can't
afford to lose here and in case you're
curious what Blackbeard's genius plan
has been all along well you should
really check out that video next right
here